hello everyone
another day another class another
lecture you know we've been touching
this subject of a couple of them really
quantum mechanics we let into what it's
science from there we went into the fact
that you know it's divided in two parts
physics and philosophy philosophy I
believe should be included under science
as long as it does explanations
it doesn't do explanations of objects
and causes and mechanism it does
explanations of what it does concepts on
the one hand you can talk about love
whatever consciousness very popular word
lately and also about reasons and
purposes and what I've been trying to
get to this week my son doesn't let me
get there but yeah and that's why I keep
title eating the same putting the same
title over and over again quantum is
irrational and that's what I wanted to
get to that that was the gist of what I
was trying to get to and you know some
of you might say you know is this worth
it to go through all this rigmarole you
know how some of these things you know
it should be deal with with all these
subjects and you know you might have
your opinion I'm saying we need to do
this we need to do this because we need
to establish what is science one thing
we need to establish whether physics and
philosophy are part of science we need
to establish what is rational you know
and I think that's where we lost our way
in mainstream so-called physics that
they they they lost their way they don't
really know what rational is anymore and
they don't care they don't care because
they're interested in their math in
their equations and so for them it
doesn't matter really
I don't think any of that matters to be
honest something dude that more to me do
you I don't think it matters
oh why to categorize things whether it's
philosophy science whether it's rational
or irrational well that's to know how
magnet works yeah you just explain to
them no they can take it or leave it
yeah that's what the show ends yeah when
the problem is there is uh I guess you
could say that there's a lot of politics
involved and it's unavoidable people
have their everybody's got their own
religion everybody defends their
religion and so that's where the
fistfights come in and people start
accusing each other to being irrational
or or you know cranks crackpots or
whatever and yeah that that's part of
the issue but then there's another issue
which is a little more objective and
that's what the definitions work on and
that's you know can we objectively say
that a theory is rational or irrational
someone can come up and give you an
explanation of something and how are you
being a judge it on the basis of their
authority oh he's got a PhD so he must
be right no if I don't care if he's got
a PhD if he comes up and he brings a an
explanation that is irrational
objectively irrational you should reject
it and say look you know what you just
proposed is I'm sorry but I don't want
to offend you but it's idiocy I thought
I defined it definition is subjective
no it's not because you define no it's
objectively irrational under your
definition no it's not
and I overruled my son because you know
I'm the boss so I get to I get that
power you know I have all thority here
you know one place where I have
authority no I'm saying it's not because
I think it's objectively irrational to
say that I'm
use a concept as an object that's that's
the main one but it's not the only one
but that is the main one what's wrong
with that
isn't that objective isn't that just how
you use the word well no but I'm
defining it that way
defiant fine is my way of defining the
word the the other person should say
okay I don't like your definition fine
what is your definition I think it's
quite objective if you establish an
objective criteria that's what I think
I'm doing yeah but when you establish
criteria when you define a word for
fussing purposes or theories for your
theory someone else use the same word in
a different way okay and that's what I
need to know whether your definer they
define its objective in the sense that
it's depending on who's using the word
no way no way no if we're gonna use the
word objective and subjective in a
rational way I mean otherwise you know
we can start questioning what what do we
mean by objective what do we mean by
subjective and what I'm saying is that
I'm saying that you know you can't just
choose and say well you know in order to
preserve my religion I'm gonna define
rationality or irrationality and such in
such way that it accommodates my
religion or better yet I'm gonna say I'm
not gonna define those words because
they can't be defined and so I just
reject them and say you know I'm not
gonna define and that's typically what
what you'll find out though you don't
have to define the word if you're not
gonna use it in your theory no no what
I'm saying is we're trying to qualify in
if possible in an objective way whether
a theory standing alone you know you
don't even know who came up with this
theory it doesn't matter you just apply
criteria to it and say is this theory
rational and I'm saying we do have
criteria now you know no I'm saying no
because the guy who says that no you're
wrong or whatever and I say this theory
is rational and not irrational
okay then you
have to define those terms what do you
mean by rational my definition of Brad
yeah okay it makes it's wrong it makes
sense to me
no no that's subjective see that subject
but then it's not objective but then
it's not objective you just ask for
definition no but I'm saying have to be
objective no but that's the point that's
the issue the issue is that I gave my
definition what's the problem I know I
know I love your point of view you're
respected I piss on it no the issue here
we're talking about detective Lee
nationality that's my but my whole point
is you can't objectively take this again
objective definition is an oxymoron
there okay because when you define a
word you're defining it so that you no
way that you want to use it no that's
what I mean I could this is my point you
could I could just as well define
rational as something that we vote is
rational that's my definition for
rational no and again all those are
subjective so far we have subjectivity
I'm talking about I'm talking about a
definition and I'm not talking about a
definition only I'm saying whether the
definition is objective and if any of
you say you know I like as soon as you
say that it's subjective who said
rational had to be objective that's not
part of my definition for rational you
know I'm not saying that that has to be
a definition I'm saying that if we're
gonna qualify a theory is objectively
rational then we have to have some
objective criteria now you can have
subject you can have a lot a different
definition of rationality I don't care
what I'm saying is in order for it to be
objectively rational we do have criteria
that's two words now I'm just using the
word rational you're you brought up
objectively rational yeah I'm seeing I
have objective criteria for right no no
no you said the phrase objectively
rational now you're adding no no by this
I mean that we
have objective criteria for rationality
and I'm and I think it's very
straightforward to say if you use a
concept as an object it's obviously is
irrational you missed my point
completely because you define the word
right in your way and I define it in a
different way
yeah but you you defined it not
objectively now regardless if if I'm
using the word or someone else is using
my definition regardless of who's using
the definition you know okay where the
server was using B's the B definition
okay its objective in the sense that
anyone can use it it's just a standalone
definition it just has a completely
different meaning and that's the part
one where I mean it's kind of like
subjective in the sense that it just
depends on how you want to use the word
I could just as well use the word dog
yeah yeah no no it's it's not that
simple what we're saying here is that we
do have objective criteria and the
criteria is you can't use a concept as
an object and that stands alone I mean a
person who wants a challenge that it
should be locked up but objective
criteria could be anything red things
are already alright you you can you can
do a devil's advocate to the extreme all
the way that it's a tighter red yeah it
means that have a red frequency yeah I
call rational and again that that is
subjective that is subjective you can
come up with any subjective thing so how
can a theory be red I'm talking about
theories is rational I'm talking about
applying the word rational only to
theories is nothing I can apply it to
people and say oh you're irrational
whatever we're saying about the word
you're talking with the notion that we
mean by irrational no I'm talking about
using the word rational in science but
then you're wrong because if I won't
even the words this chair
right they can just as well say this
chair is rational by my definition yeah
and and you can say anything you want my
point in my point is that you know you
need to define the word rational in an
objective you have let me finish you
need to define the word rational in an
objective manner just to apply it to
it's like saying I'm gonna breathe it's
like it's like you're getting a point
but it's not a planet and I'm not gonna
get the point ever because I create a
meter and and that's gonna be my
standard you know and and I'm gonna say
okay this measures 5 meters and you
can't say well that doesn't matter if I
meter yeah because I've already defined
the standard it's kind of like that I'm
saying I'm gonna be defining in a in an
objective way I'm gonna they find the
word rational so that I can apply it to
a theory and if it's not it doesn't fall
under those criteria yeah it's not gonna
be right so it's gonna fall under
religions gonna be irrational it's just
that since the way you know because then
then the other person has the option
yeah and and people are gonna reject it
because they're saying that's subjective
it's subjective because now you're
giving an opinion your now you're no
longer yeah you can make it to whatever
extreme you want but the point is you're
overruled the point here is that we have
to define the word rational in an
objective way we have an objective
criteria you can't use the word love as
a physical object period is a lot you
can't do that now there is no noise it's
black or white there's a lot of nuance
when it comes to defining words not that
word yeah we can call it a no problem I
can you call it a and I can call it a in
and the theory has to be a and it can't
be beat that's my point okay but then
and the other guy has the other guy has
the option of saying well I don't agree
with you're a fine you don't know
with a please define a or give me a bomb
no there's no no big and let me tell you
and everyday I have proof I have proof
serious a could mean anything I have
proof that's the good part I have proof
you don't and the proof is let me tell
you what the proof is the proof is
several people came over already at
least I'd say five people at least have
come over and challenged okay what do
you mean by rationality I guess they
didn't see the the article that I had on
rationality and so I went in there and
pointed them to the to my version of
rationality and a couple of them came
came back they never read the article
finally they read the article and they
never came back I said look if you don't
like my definition no problem give me
your definition well they never came
back they never define rationality they
just want to argue but they have no
alternative to what I'm proposing if you
say you know you're gonna use a concept
as an object clearly it is an irrational
theory well whatever you're proposing I
don't care because it's worthless
because you know you you can't challenge
that it's it's unchallengeable and I
want them to define the word in such a
way that its objective not that they say
well I like the color red but you know I
don't care what you like but defining
you're just giving a criteria so you use
my criteria irrational is any are we
going that's subjective
that's a anything that comes out of your
mouth is subjective obviously it's
subjective because he came out of your
mouth and not in the world doesn't share
that it's it's your personal opinion I'm
not saying here that this is my opinion
I'm saying that I'm applying a very
objective criteria saying that I'm gonna
say that anything anyone who uses a
concept as an object is clearly
irrational what's wrong with that I want
you to now tell me why it's wrong what's
wrong with it
don't don't don't try to play just
devil's habit tell me why using a
concept as an object is Iraq is not
irrational tell me why it's rational in
the way you use no no tell me why it's
not no you gotta you got to answer the
question don't allude it why the
question is why using a concept as an
object why is that rational or why is
that not irrational answer the question
don't don't come with some nonsense no
no answer the question you can't answer
the question because it is an irrational
proposal because I have already the end
the answer is that there is no way
that's the question of a gas okay then
answer it what's the question why is it
not why is it not irrational to say that
you use a concept ism is an object well
there's nothing wrong with that using
the word love as a stone is that not
irrational
yeah using the word love as a stone can
you do that does that make any sense
those people should be locked up those
people are irrational yes yes no okay
then it's subjective but the point is
that's irrational those people should be
locked up person who uses the word love
as a stone should be locked up accordion
II he needs he needs help it depends on
who uses the word that's just for the
safety you have mathematical physicists
who use the word rational in a
completely different sense they're not a
weird because they're not aware of what
they're doing they're moving masses
around yeah yeah but it makes sense to
them know it so they say or at least
they think it makes sense to them let's
put it that way they are convinced that
everything's fine so they are they're
not aware of the problem they're simply
not aware of the problem they're not
they're not aware that they're using
concepts is up but that's a product
Enders rationale
to do with awareness well yeah obviously
if you point it out and the guy
insistent you got to lock him up I mean
if he if you get a PhD a guy who studied
ten years at the University and he
doesn't realize that he's moving
concepts that he's moving wave functions
the smashing wave country he's
accelerating wave functions or
probability waves or whatever they call
him then he's got a problem I mean as
long as he deals with his math he's okay
but once you've pointed out and say look
how does this relate to physic you're
saying that there's a physical object
called a wave function and if the guy
says yes he has to be locked up he's got
to be put in an asylum I mean the guy
lost his mind
I mean hopefully the guy who you know
realized that that he's in there he's
gonna say well no yeah it's not a
physical thing we use this in math okay
fine he can give her any expression he
wants but if he really confuses a
wavefunction for a particle for a for a
stone we got a problem there we got a
problem and again you know that's what
I'm saying you can't you we do have an
objective criteria for that now if there
are people out there who you know are
out of their minds and they they move
love around they believe in spirits and
whatever and okay fine you know we don't
deal with those people but a PhD a guy
who's got ten years at the University if
he doesn't realize the difference we got
a big problem we we have to have an
objective criteria for rationality and
especially at the you know at the
professional level anyways the point is
that you know I do have a chart the
chart shows that you know we do have
this breakdown of rational science into
physics and philosophy and separate it
from religion religion includes opinions
and belief and religion also includes
irrational theories and supernatural
theories and under rational science and
that works rational I put it in there we
can just put science in there science
has to be rational so we do not need to
clarify it but again
we have to have a definition for
rational otherwise it should fall under
irrationality which means it's going to
go under religion and here's the
definition or the criteria at least
conversion of concepts into objects
that's one issue the other one is using
undefined words or using them in
consistently throughout a dissertation
that's obviously not consistent that's
not rational that's not scientific that
the theory doesn't follow from the
assumption that's got to be also a
criteria and I put a fourth one in there
and that's when the guy thinks he's
explained something when he only
described it and so the those are the
criteria I'm using I think those are
quite objective now you know someone
might add someone might subtract but if
you don't agree with any of them we got
a problem because you know we got to
define what what is rational if we're
gonna disqualify a theory as being
rational everybody wants to be rational
and they say Oh according to my theory
or the way I look at things I'm rational
no no here we have an objective
criterion the guy can't can't say well
I'm rational but I don't agree with your
definition no I think I've got a problem
with that you know and again you know
people can argue to the end of the earth
if they want but here we have a
objective criteria we have to have some
criteria to determine who is rash and on
the planet and yeah mathematicians do
are gonna suffer with this they won't
like this I also have a definition for
the word knowledge people might not like
it but knowledge the ability to predict
the outcome of an experiment without
error and the reason I have to define
that word is that people who bring the
word knowledge into science I think
that's an error science does not deal
with knowledge and you know any again
the alternatives for the skeptic for the
devil's advocate to define the word
knowledge and yell terminator you know
you can't insist that you've got
knowledge to not be able to define the
word knowledge and I'm saying this is
what you guys are saying if they don't
agree well then they have to come up
with a definition and today we're still
with plato's justified true belief and
those issues have to those basis
to be touched those points have to be
crossed out at some point so what's the
issue the issue is that quantum
mechanics is irrational under those
criteria okay what's what's wrong with
quantum mechanics well here you have one
issue
the first one is entanglement okay and
what is entanglement these people have
no idea how a particle here affects one
over there and I'm not talking one
across the room I'm talking one that's a
billion light years away they say no
matter where the particle is in the
universe this one affects that one
that's what they've come up with and
they come up with I guess through their
mathematics their equations they say one
particle effects another one at a
distance if one is is going clockwise
the other one is going counterclockwise
when you turn the first one
counterclockwise the second one goes
clockwise well you know and when you see
here the here's the illustration and you
can see they always connect them with
something there's a little line
connecting those two particles there and
no matter where they stretch and they
always put that that artificial
connection like if they were connected
and you know that that's the rope right
there and there's another version of it
also showing a rope you know under the
rope you can imagine why you know from
one end it's counterclockwise from the
other end it's clockwise and vice-versa
have you turned it around both should
turn in the opposite direction and they
never figure that out they keep dealing
with discrete particles but then this is
what they illustrate the illustrate
connected particles and again you know
these things are stuff that you know we
have these contradictions we have to
determine whether any of this is
rational and what happens with that you
know here you have the
you know the entanglement in in just in
a frozen state here you have two
particles how does particle B affect a
how does particle a affect B and you
cannot even imagine how one can affect
the other unless there is some kind of
you know connection like it's shown in
in you know in all these cases you see
some kind of rope some kind of
connection some kind of elongated medium
between them and you we already covered
the gluons but that's good to show as
well you know how do they illustrate the
gluon is a spring that extends between
two particles
well yeah anyone can do you know action
at a distance like that but is a glue on
a perfect is is a glue on a bed spring
or is it a particle and again they they
call it a particle which is not even a
particle and then they illustrate it as
a bed spring and so they cheat they they
get away with all this stuff because
they realize that what they're proposing
is not rational and that's where the
problem is the problem is you know these
people in quantum mechanics if these is
not rational at all but that's not where
rationality stops in quantum mechanics
it continues here they say that a
particle can be at two places at once
not only can two particles occupy the
same space something forbidden in the
macro world and let's concede that one
let's assume two particles can somehow
blend and become one okay
that's kind of like easier to see but
for one particle to be at two places at
once you know that that is totally
irrational and in fact they recognize it
I put a video out there on quantum
mechanics showing all these people very
skeptical you know they're all quantum
mechanics they're all mathematicians who
believe in quantum mechanics but then
they have you know these ideas that you
know you can't understand quantum
mechanics why because they have things
like you know one particle being at two
places at once
and of course that's totally irrational
you
cannot under any circumstance accept
that and these people are saying they
are willing to accept that and again the
question is whether they're talking real
or they're doing politics you know I
don't know you get a confront them like
on TV in front of the reporters and find
out do you really mean that a particle
can be at two places at once and let
them you know tell the world that they
actually believe in that you know
because again in my mind it's totally
irrational it's not even worth
considering and where did they get that
well they get that from quantum
superposition here you have
Schrodinger's cat cat is both alive and
dead until you look so so they're saying
the cat has both states the cat is both
alive and dead and this is again an
analogy for half what happens in the
quantum world they're saying a particle
hat can have two states it can have a an
excited state and a non excited state at
the same time and it turns into an
excited state or into non excited state
as soon as you touch it or see it or do
whatever with it like if we're affecting
you know the the conditions of the
quantum world just by staring or by
trying to measure it or detect it and
we're did to get all this stuff well
they get this stuff from
you know the slit experiment that's
where it all comes from at least that's
one of the sources or the most important
source and here you have it according to
quantum the particles can be at two
places at once that's one particle
leaving the source and turning into a
wave it kind of spreads out and turns
into two particles it's everywhere at
once or at least at two places at once
and yeah anybody can do explanations
like that you know I mean
you know if you if you bring in magic
anybody can explain the slit experiment
and the question is what value does this
have if you know a particle can be at
two places at once or it converts into a
wave just when you need it yeah you know
that's you know what is this is this
science and and you know here I have it
under my version we have under the
needle experiment that I've done and
here I have a this is the real
experiment that I did it's two-cent
experiment doesn't cost billions of
dollars shown a monochromatic light out
of a laser it goes through the sides of
that needle and you go it to the end of
the wall and you can see that the you
will see the fringes there are the
fringes so you can produce the fringes
without the slits and and now we have a
problem because you know if if a
particle hits the needle suppose the it
breaks in two so it's or it's two places
at once
but then it should go sideways it won't
converge up on the screen and interfere
with each other and so you cannot
explain it with particle under any
circumstance the only way you can
explain this is with the wave properties
of light and in this case we're saying
you know light is not a two-dimensional
transverse wave we're saying that it's a
torsion wave and that's a totally
different monster not only does it
explain the speed but it explains why
there is interference both constructive
and destructive interference and and
yeah and here here is my illustration of
what we see under the rope model you
have before you turn the light on the
all the ropes are connected now you're
going to turn the light on that means
you're gonna stimulate each of the ropes
connected from the source to the sides
of the needle which are connected to the
screen or whatever you have
the background where you're gonna you
know illuminate the whatever you're
trying to illuminate whatever thing you
have in the background and what happens
as soon as you turn the light on you
increase the frequency you have shorter
wavelengths and now you can you the
light comes into the visible range for
ours and you see the eye there watching
okay and what happens the the Rope is
connected to the sides of the needle and
to an atom that's at the side of the
needle and that atom is connected to the
wall and you know and where you see the
bright bands it means you have
constructive interference that means the
waves are in phase and where you have
the dark bands you have waves that are
out of phase in other words the the wave
coming from one side of the needle is
offset by a half a wavelength from the
one on the coming from say the right
side of the needle and and that
reflection comes to your eye remember
your eye is also connected to every atom
on the screen so you're getting that
reflection into your eye and that's
essentially the explanation for the slit
experiment no magic no particle will be
in the two places at once we don't need
any of that nonsense we can do it all
with ropes and again we didn't do it
with a needle we don't need the slit at
all and so you know again a lot of these
conclusions about you know the cat being
both alive and dead have to do with a
slit experiment they have to explain
somehow the slit experiment with
particles and that's what they came up
with they said well you know our best
exploration the particle is at two
places at once how did they arrive that
at that point they said look we covered
one of the slits and then we don't get
any interference pattern meaning that
you know the the particle could not
interfere with itself that's that
because they're they're under the
impression they're emitting one photon
or one electron if it's done with
electrons one photon or one electron at
a time that's what they think they're
doing and so they say well we're
only one photon or one electron and if
we cover one of the slits then it
doesn't interfere so it means that that
particle is not at two places anymore
now it's only at one place he can't
interfere with itself
that's that's the explanation that's how
they got to that that's that's their
explanation anyways that's we have what
entanglement we have the two places at
once all those are rational you can't
explain entanglement you can't explain
action at a distance with with particles
you can't explain the slit experiment
with particles and then obviously we
have the cloud model of the atom which
showed the other day here it is again
and that's the hydrogen atom and you
have all those bees buzzing around and
instead of having one electron going
around I think you'll see it here in a
minute yeah that one there see it should
be one electron going around that's not
what they have what they have is a bunch
of bees and this is supposed to
represent the fact that you know all
these electrons are just one electron
but the electron is everywhere at once
so you know it's like they cover every
base you know a bee anybody can explain
stuff you know with magic and that's
what they're doing here they're saying
the electron is everywhere at once and
again all these are irrationalities of
quantum none none of them are rational
and the worst part is they admit it they
say you know all this is irrational and
what they mean by that is we don't
understand it and what they mean by that
is that well you know our way of
thinking about the universe is not the
way the universe runs the universe is
rational but we don't have the
intelligence to understand it that's
that's their explanation for that and
and finally we have you know the
orbitals where they convert an orbital
which is a region where you can find the
electron and they convert the orbital
itself into a balloon that merges with
another so-called balloon from another
atom and forms a molecule you know and
again it's it's converting concepts into
objects so you know
under the criteria that I'm proposing
all this is irrational
my son doesn't like my definition what
do I do
should I hang him kill him what should I
do with my son
he says it's subjective but then if it's
subjective we're gonna tolerate all this
stuff we're gonna say okay the hell with
science because then science is it can
go and do whatever it wants well like I
said science is really just if someone
wants to know someone comes to you with
the question yeah I was gravity work
you're giving your answer it doesn't
matter whether it's rational irrational
whether it's magic not magical what
regardless you just try to answer the
question and they can take it or leave
and that's what the show ends yeah but
what happens when when a guy because
he's got authority because he's got a
PhD and people say oh here's this sage
this genius in math and they have this
you know breathtaking feeling of oh I'm
in the presence of God here and the guy
says look the particle can be at two
places at once and the guy says oh
please give me your autograph you know
does this have anything to do with
science the fact that the guy gave you
an explanation but is the explanation is
not even the only a ration it's
ridiculous I mean what are we supposed
to do with that are we supposed to just
accept it because that's the status quo
the status quo is that every University
on the planet every think-tank on the
planet they talk about this nonsense
they say the particle can be in two
places at once this particle can affect
that one from a distance we don't know
how by magic you know we might as well
bring traditional religion back and say
oh well let's just do it with spirits
why did we go into what do we call
science if it's not going to be rational
if we don't have a criteria for
rationality that's my question
it's really just if a person accepts
whatever answer they get then that's
that's the end of the show but doesn't
matter how much I scream from the
sidelines if the person takes it on
Authority or my obvious whatever
obviously they're whether they're doing
science or not you can call it science
or not but that's just this there's no
doubt there you know if the guy wants to
believe in God right
and you can't convince him that there is
no God
well yeah you're not gonna convince him
you know so it's the guy's gonna
continue believing in God what my what
I'm proposing is some criteria some
objective criteria we can say look these
guys who claim to be doing science
that's just another religion because all
these people are saying is you know that
they're they're proposing irrational
explanations and unless we can get that
word irrational in there people who are
not aware who are not aware of the
arguments you know they're gonna
continue asking for autographs but if
you say look let me point out some
objective criteria where you can judge
it on your own well you don't have to
rely on now 30 when you don't have to
have a PhD to understand what these guys
are saying I'm saying you know just go
in there and ask this guy that you're
gonna ask for an autograph to say look
can a particle be at two places at once
and if the guy says yes then don't ask
him for his autograph because you're
asking for an autograph from a patient
that belongs in an asylum at that point
you you you gotta use your own criteria
and say look this guy is talking
nonsense yeah but if you're not aware of
the arguments because there is no
standard because you have no criteria
for rationality then the guy gets away
with murder and everybody's just gonna
ask for their autographs there's not
gonna be a challenge to that we got to
do something I mean about this there's
not up to us that's my point it's not we
have to do something it's hores
listening
they're what we would call the rational
theory what was listening it either
dawns on them or doesn't but only if
they have a great cheer yeah but no
because again most people either take it
or don't regardless of whether they have
these criterias it's it's more like a
gut feeling like you know listening to
someone like many times I'm listening to
someone and you can kind of like after a
few you know videos of them there's you
can kind of tell where they're coming
from whether they're they're kind of on
point or whether there's something shady
going on or whether there's or whether
they're just dumb but sometimes you need
that argument sometimes you need someone
to come up with an argument that
suddenly wakes you up let me give you an
example that someone said something the
other day that woke me up unrelated
topic but it's related to what we're
talking about and I wasn't aware of that
argument but when they make you see the
argument you say oh that's an
interesting one and I had to do with a
transsexual and this woman she's
campaigning against transsexuality she's
she has her own opinions I don't agree
with everything she says but I like one
argument that she made and she said you
can change your sex you know you can cut
that thing out and throw it to the dogs
turn yourself into a woman but you
cannot change your white chromosomes and
she's totally right
you know in that sense I had to give
120% credit to her but I wasn't aware of
the argument unless unless you wise ins
me and makes me aware of that argument
you know I may not see that argument at
all and that that's what I'm referring
to here I'm saying that here I'm saying
look I'm gonna give you some criteria
you know for rational people who
understand that you can't use a concept
as an object and they're not aware of
that specific subject and they're just
listening like hypnotizing is here oh
that's oh and I was one of them I used
to listen to Carl Sagan you know and it
was just like oh you know I didn't
realize the problems of what he was
saying until you know I had to figure
for myself and then I said Jesus this
guy is talking nonsense but only when
you have an argument or someone wisent
you to that argument then you can at
least have a point of comparison doesn't
mean you're gonna accept it it just
means that at least you have something
to compare it against but if you don't
have that other you know that other
option someone doesn't make you aware of
some of the pitfalls or the arguments of
what these guys are saying you may be
just brainwashed or hypnotized or
whatever you want to call you you're
just a zombie you know listening there
and you're not you're not really you
know but producing any thought you're
just absorbing all that stuff and it's
going from one ear to the other that's
what you did there because you had
already made up your mind on the issue
and you just added another argument to
your arsenal and it's the same thing
with the people listening to the
mathematicians they already made up
their mind all right they're not they're
not using their brain in that sense
asleep they just they already made up
their mind they're just kind of adding
more to the file just like you do with
the transverse state yeah but see the
point is that unless you are aware of
it's like when you deal with arguments
or with debates when people come up with
different ideas different arguments and
you're you're aware of all these
arguments but only if you're listening
yeah yeah fine but what I'm saying is if
nobody if nobody brings up new arguments
then then you're only stuck with what
you have in your head and you know
whatever you've got in there and you'll
just continue with that and you're safe
there you've got the safety net where
you're okay you're understand in your
own way that everything's okay but
someone suddenly in fact you said that
yesterday about you know the flat
earthers it doesn't mean you're him
you're gonna believe in what the flat
earthers say but if the flat earther
might come you know he's got a way a
different way of thinking obviously no
doubt about it there the guy comes in
there and says look you know the way I
look at the world is this way and he
criticizes the mainstream from a
specific angle it doesn't mean you're
gonna accept what he says but at least
it makes you think
from a different angle say oh I see how
this guy is thinking and that alone is
worth something you know at least it
said it widens your horizons with
whatever that's where maybe it just
widens at one inch maybe a meter I don't
know but it why does your horizons but
if you didn't have that guy there you
know you wouldn't have that angle and I
think that is good that that enriches
your your overall ideas of about things
it makes you take a better decision on
whether to accept you know what you hear
out there that's all I'm saying
you know what man can I take a rain
check out that Oh 30 is out is a bad
deal because you know what our 30 means
a 30 means you're allowing someone to
vote for you imagine if let's put it in
that context you know you're a citizen
you're allowed to vote out there and you
can vote Republican or Democrat or
whatever and it turns out that someone
comes to you and says look just stay at
home and drink some beer I'm gonna vote
for you and I'll bow for your wife I'll
go for your neighbor I'll vote for all
you folks out here to just give me your
your ID and I'll vote for all of you we
would you do it would you think that's a
good idea but that's but but that's what
it may be no no but but what I'm saying
that's what we're doing in science we're
saying oh I'm gonna let the
mathematician vote for me yeah there is
a use for that
okay what's the use time yeah time is
are you saying that you don't want to
waste time or my whole point of
authority is we don't all have time to
figure out how to do plumbing how to be
a doctor
time to do everything I just need me the
physics stuff to the physicists these
the chemistry stuff to the chemists
leave the doctors and the doctors I'm a
plumber I'll fit I'll do the plumbing
for everyone the doctors will do the
doctoring for everyone so that's the
whole reason of authorities we don't
have time to be the jack-of-all-trades
we don't have time I mean you spend so
much time yeah making on these things
and you still get something like there's
still some Frick on the on the fringes
of the things you've investigated
there's still room to be discovered on
collars after the 20 years you've
invested over there having got the
foundations of anything so imagine a
plumber he's not gonna just be like oh
let's start let's open up the book of
physics and get started no he's got
other things yeah but let me ask you if
you ask that question to people say look
you're a citizen you can vote but just
give me your ID and helpful for you see
how many how many people would actually
do that how many button people would
actually grant that you vote for them
yeah you might say that but I'm 100%
convinced that people won't do that they
will not allow you to vote for them no
but I'm almost sure give my vote to
people because I don't because you don't
care but I mean people who vote because
if you're not forced to vote you may not
even care hold on what is voting if not
giving your power to someone else yeah
but here yes but here you're doing it
indirectly because you don't know what
the guys gonna do with your vote you may
you may be a Republican you don't know
if this guy's gonna vote Democrat maybe
for you know nobody you vote Hillary you
don't know what she's gonna do no no no
you know but it's different it's
different if if you're a vote if you a
voter who cares that's a different you
and cares no not Trump no right right
but now the Nana flips it around there's
something else correct
but but but this is the point the point
is you're a person who cares about
politics you're going over there and the
guy who comes in and said interrupts you
and he says look I'll vote for you and
you say well okay
you're gonna vote for me yeah and he
doesn't tell you who he was gonna vote
for he says I'll vote for you now it
turns out that you know you want to vote
for Trump you know or Republican or
whatever and turns out the other guy you
know you don't know if he's gonna vote
for in the same way you wanna vote he
might vote for the Democrats
how many people who are like that would
give their ID I'm saying there's not one
not one who would do it but my whole
point is they're already drunk they want
something but I don't really know what
he's doing but I'm just saying vote
someone in you're essentially giving
your power to someone you have no idea
what they're gonna do but it's besides
giving your vote this nobody having no
idea whether they're gonna vote for the
thing you want and that's for sure
that's the way it always worked but the
point is that that I'm trying to say is
people don't rationalize it like that
when people say look just give me your
ID and I'll vote for you people will say
no and you can say but you're doing the
same thing by giving that to Trump and
they don't realize that they're doing
that but they don't see it that way they
say no no if I'm gonna vote I'm gonna
vote for a Republican or I'm gonna vote
for Democrat I'm gonna do the vote II
I'm not gonna let you do the voting for
me
it turns out that you know my son is
right yeah you know the the guy up there
finally decides to do one thing or the
other according to his own you know
biases or whatever or his needs
political needs and so in the end it
amounts to the same thing but people
won't see it that way people simply will
not grant their vote to someone else to
vote for them no way even though they're
doing the same thing by voting you know
for the candidate yeah but then but then
the question is why do we allow it for
physics in other words if we don't allow
it in politics people know people won't
do it don't insist because people won't
do it then we just
stablish that they are doing that no no
they're not I won't give I'll give my
vote to trump but I won't give my vote
to someone who votes for me no no
intermediary meteor mania nobody just
it's the same thing it's the same thing
your people don't see it that way that's
my point people don't see it that way
people don't see people will give their
vote to trumpet they will not give the
vote to someone to vote for them for
Trump that's my point
and why do we allow that in physics why
do we give the boat to the physicists
and say you vote for me for your theory
we're doing it in physic but we don't
allow it in politics and that's the
issue the issues you know we were doing
the same thing that we would not do in
pubs were doing that in physics and
that's the problem the problem is that
you should do your thinking for yourself
you should do the voting for yourself
but you know my son says you know you we
don't have the time to do all the
research so we accept this substitute to
represent us and that's a serious
problem it's a serious problem because
we're allowing someone to decide for us
he's putting his brain in my brain
that's what he's doing he's voting for
me that's a serious problem and that's
what the status quo today we have all
this 99% of humanity doesn't even care
about physics or science and are
allowing the physicist to do the voting
for them to to decide the issues for
them and this is where the issue is and
if these people are doing irrational
stuff that they're coming up with
irrationalities then you know we have a
problem because then we have to decide
you know first what is rational and then
allow the people to realize as many as
we can possibly find out there that can
see that you know these guys are
irrational but a lot of the people out
there who are you know pretty rational
folk intelligent people they're not
aware of the arguments right now and
until those people see the arguments
you know well you know there's gonna be
no change so so it has to start at that
basic level you have to at least make
them aware you have to put some criteria
in this case rationality what is
rational what is not and if you use a
concept as an object well you know I
think that's straightforward that is
irrational and if you don't define your
terms that's irrational and you want to
use an end it's critical in your theory
then it's irrational and if your theory
doesn't follow for humorous from your
assumptions
that's your ration and so on down the
line so you know I think people should
be made aware of what the criteria are
so that they can start using their own
heads instead of having the quizzes vote
for them anyways that's the story for
today and we'll see you again on Sunday
see that same time same station